back in the good old days if you are an
ambitious Empire Builder looking to
expand your territory and power you just
ran up the troops and invade wherever
you please but that came with a myriad
of problems the plebs in the country
you're invading would retaliate and not
comply you lose some of your own troops
who aren't replaceable but would be
better off fighting in a bigger war if
necessary today other global superpowers
like Russia could rebel to protect their
allies and with the advent of nuclear
weapons that's a risk you probably
shouldn't take and most importantly
you've built animosity with everyone you
ruled over as more and more men came
home maimed or dead all free or trivial
pursuits of power so over all violently
invading other countries you want to
capture just isn't a very good public
relations move because as we all know if
the general public despises you no
matter how big no matter how much power
you have it will eventually lead to your
downfall
today's leaders and superpowers no
different though in today's modern world
we needed a different strategy where we
get the same outcome control over
another country to expand our empire
make more money get access to their
natural resources etc but without all
the negatives that come with an all-out
invasion we needed a way where the
people being concrete don't even realize
that their conquered enter dead
[Music]
in many ways it's like a colonial war
the difference is that these days people
and the resources are controlled not by
viceroys and occupying armies but by
other more sophisticated means of which
the principal weapon is dead dirt is the
most subtle and effective form of
imperialism the world has ever known
debt is as powerful as a bullet but
comes off as a rose here's how it works
let's say you've got a huge construction
company or engineering company that
specializes in massive power plants
hydroelectric plants or overall civil
engineering infrastructure or maybe
you're a very powerful politician with a
stake and big private companies like
these which has been very common in the
last few decades you all want the same
thing more money and more power but
there are always so many giant new
infrastructure projects first four
countries need because they're already
first world countries so if you can't
get new business domestically how are
you supposed to grow your business and
profits the answer third world countries
or as organizations that the UN call
them least developed countries or LDCs
LDCs are nearly the perfect customers to
build your empire with because they're
so underdeveloped they don't have much
infrastructure to start with electricity
running water roads buildings hospitals
schools all of which you provide and
since they've never had any of this it's
pretty easy to justify that hey if we
build this stuff for you but your people
and your economy will be a lot better
off and would love you for it and boom
you almost have a multi-billion dollar
strategy but we're not quite there yet
the biggest problem standing in the way
is just that there are least developed
nations meaning that they don't have
much money to pay you for these
expensive projects to bring them into
the modern world because if they did
have that money well they wouldn't be
considered less than development that is
where the magic of debt in the form of
foreign aid comes in see most people
view foreign aid as a generous things
like wow we're helping third world
countries that's so kind of us honey but
for the most part but for the most part
he was especially those in power don't
do things out of the kindness of their
hearts without other motives at play
that's not necessarily a bad thing it's
just human nature
and as
big construction engineering company you
love foreign aid because countries that
previously couldn't afford your services
all of a sudden can and even if just one
of these projects go through thanks to a
third world country getting a giant loan
that's a good few billion dollars in
your pocket that you wouldn't have
earned otherwise as a high-ranking
politician you also love LDCs taking on
massive debt because the more entrenched
a country is in your debt the more they
struggle to pay back the loan the more
and waste down their population the more
power you have over it you can ask them
for favors you can persuade them to vote
for your interests in organizations like
the UN you can put shadow Jetix military
bases on their soil get access to the
oil or rainforest and much more and of
course as a bank you also be getting a
metric ton of interest on these giant
loans so you're pretty happy to so as
you can see there's a pretty big
incentive for us not to only get these
countries in debt but to burying them in
debt because the bigger the debt the
more interest money resources empowered
you're gonna get back in return and if
you've noticed all the benefits of
third-world debt are nearly exactly the
same as what you get if you just
straight-up invaded and took over these
countries by force in the old way of
imperialism once you took over a
territory your nation's businesses had
more customers to work with your banks
had more loans to give out and thus more
interest to be collected and of course
your government got more control and
more power over more people but with the
new way of imperialism third-world debt
you get the exact same things but the
fundamental difference is that with the
old way of doing things those being
worldview you the ruler as the enemy
what debt those being world view you as
the Savior but there's still one more
hurdle to get through if the goal is to
entrench countries in so much debt that
they can't ever pay it off how would you
get any country or any Bank for that
matter to agree to such a deceptive
proposition simple salesmen
they say the best salesmen are the ones
that make the prospects feel like
they're not even being sold to that it
was their own decision to buy that's
what we got a deal with these pesky
third world countries to get them to
take on these massive loans and it's not
as hard as you may think
see third world countries have a ton of
pain points as you can imagine people
are starving undereducated don't have
clean running water don't have
electricity and the people in power are
often corrupt and just want more power
and money
so to convince them we just have to play
off of these pain points but instead of
just sending in annoying door-to-door
salesmen to these countries we just send
an economists engineers analysts and
other people with very respectable
titles these people's jobs are to study
the economy of the nation and make
economic projections and studies of
where the country might be 10 20 years
down the road if they had a shiny new
hydroelectric plant built for example
how much would the economy grow how much
would the gross national product grow
how many people will be lifted from
absolute poverty and be given sufficient
water nourishment and education how much
money would the world families get in
return if they went with the plan the
more optimistic the projections are the
more eager the leaders of the country
will be to take on the debt and the
bigger the project can be justified and
of course a bigger project comes with a
bigger loan so really all the
responsibility of making this entire
scheme work entrenching desperate
countries in debt rests on the shoulders
of these professionals making these
projections if they fail to convince the
government that they need these
infrastructure projects these companies
lose out on billions of dollars so it's
pretty safe to say that that's probably
a pretty big incentive to be a little
extra optimistic with the numbers and
now more than ever with all the research
fraud coming up in the news we can see
that when data is buried and obscured
and technical jargon twisting studies to
show the projections you want it's not
too hard especially when we're talking
about predicting 10 20 years into the
future
your guess of how the future might look
is as good as anyone elses and if you
get this step right the banks will
approve of loans and these plebeian
countries will happily take the Trojan
horse
and debts are exactly the same thing
except for one point which is that
nobody needs to occupy territory today
[Music]
this kind of thing has been happening
since around the 1970s and I guess it's
been pretty effective so far because why
else would developing countries still
have a growing seven point eight
trillion dollars in debt in 2018 alone
and still be developing think about that
for a second never mind that interest
payments alone on a seven point eight
trillion dollars that's pure profits to
the banks all of the seven point eight
trillion went directly from the banks to
the developing countries and straight
back into the companies isn't that
beautiful so the money kind of just
moved around and never left the
developed world except now it's on the
backs of these third-world people to pay
back the loans and more instead of
putting that money back into the people
in poverty on top of that because it's
not easy keeping these giant
infrastructure projects maintained will
have even more money coming in in the
future in the form of maintenance what
about all this virtual control over
these countries that we keep talking
about how is that played out well it's
been pretty good half of all low income
countries or at a high risk of
defaulting on all their debt that's a
lot of leverage and just like that in
one relatively swift move you sir have
just secured the back for billions in
profits and depending on the size of
loan for all intents and purposes you
virtually conquered a country without
firing a single bullets no dead soldiers
no potential retaliation not that much
bad press either now I know you're
thinking but Jake how can I possibly
live with myself doing this to these
poor countries can't we make money and
help people at the same time what just
just take a deep breath and think of
yourself as a soldier when a soldier
first takes a man's life he questions
himself he questions his morality he
thinks about how the victim's family
might feel but as time goes on as he
takes more
and more battles it doesn't affect him
as much anymore it's kind of just part
of the job or in other words he's grown
into a professional soldier and that's
what you gotta be a professional soldier
in this new game of imperialism so sit
back relax and bask in all that sweet
third-world profit it's midnight here on
a Sunday
and I'm here making videos because
apparently I don't have this thing
called social life but regardless
welcome to the watch the end Club and
this video was primarily based on the
book Confessions of an economic hitman
written by a man named John Perkins who
was an actual like one of those
professionals that we talked about in
this video that went into these
countries and his job as a chief
economist was to convince these
countries like Ecuador Panama Indonesia
to take on these massive infrastructure
projects so if you found this video
interesting I highly recommend you check
out this book because believe it or not
it's even like way more controversial
than the stuff I covered in this video
so if you're interested output and then
fill in link below this video because
this video definitely wouldn't have been
possible without this book and you guys
get to learn more and form your own
opinion on this very very complex
subject if you enjoy video essays like
this on the most interesting and
provocative stuff in the world of
business I highly encourage you and just
like beg of you like all you have to do
is just to click that subscribe button
below this video and turn on that
notification bell too because the more
people watching just like you the more
videos and the better the videos I get
to make like this and you know it's free
and you can unsubscribe and dislike
whenever you want so just
click those buttons below if you want to
support this channel financially which
also helps me out like a lot too you can
check out some of the amazing products
for myself and my partners including
that book down below so I'm gonna free
some of them are paid and all of them
are really good that's gonna wrap it up
for this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome I've been
Jake I'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]